[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
christy wright and
joining me today is dr john deloney
welcome john how are you hey we've never
hosted together today
are they going to regret this they might
but if you're driving down the road and
you've never
witnessed a train wreck live you may
want to hang on
i'm so excited to host with john because
he is a loose cannon you never know what
he's gonna say
and that's what my wife says and i
disagree
here's here's what's great is um we are
here for you
we are taking your calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five
um give us a call about your time that's
what we're focusing on today john
because in case you didn't know
today's a big day huh it's a big day
give me a drum roll
i'm drunk rolling this is huge man today
my book lunches
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance so
this is a great day to answer your
questions about life balance or time
management that's obviously been a big
focus for me recently and today
with the launch of the book but of
course you know john is an expert on
mental health and
managing anxiety which actually
time and anxiety go together but listen
one thing i am
terrible at oh i'm so ready for this
terrible is time management
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna step
out in the lobby and make a few calls to
you
today because i'm i'm i'm really awful
okay i'm awful well let's just let's
just make you our first caller john what
tell me i'm genuinely curious are you
kidding or are you really bad at me
oh man if my wife listened to the show
she would have pulled over and raised
her hands like an old
she may just call in right now just to
vouch for this but listen
um i like to do everything sure i don't
like saying no
okay and everyone listening can relate
to not even out of like a sense of guilt
i literally love to do just about
everything okay i like doing stuff yeah
i like mowing and i like writing this
book i'm working on and i like
chit chatting and i like playing my
music i like playing with the kids i
like doing everything
which means at the end of the day i
often end up doing nothing very well
and i go to bed really scattered and i
don't sleep good and my kids feel like
they got a part of me but not all of it
my wife's like hey
you're sitting at the table but you're
not with us and then man
and i'm finding myself driving 90 miles
an hour to work and i'm just feel like
i'm chaos
all the time and you're looking at me
like yeah just like you started the show
but i like everything but man
i've i'm just terrible at time
management well it's interesting because
i so relate to that my default answer
to any question anytime anywhere is yes
yes i would love to do that yes i'll do
this and i'll go there
because it's all good it all sounds fun
i'm very excited i did learn
early on into my marriage that my
husband's default answer is not
yes to all these social events he's more
of an introvert that kind of taught me
about
you know how to have conversations
before i commit us to things every day
of the week which was a learning
experience
but i think you make a good point
because so many people
have a lot of interests and they're all
good things
so it may not even just be that they're
a people pleaser that's certainly one
problem a lot of people have
but in our world where the opportunities
are endless and
they're good opportunities there's fun
things going on every night of the week
there's fun things you could get
involved in you want to do them you try
to do them and i think that's one of the
things i've
been fascinated by in researching for
this book is
what we have tried to do is we've tried
to take something that has fixed
our time 24 hours in a day it is that is
fixed it is a
it is an absolute you you can make more
money you cannot make more time
but instead of cutting things out or
editing or choosing the best things
or even really putting a lot of thought
to our decisions
we just try to run faster we try to cram
more in
oh i just need to multitask better i
need to be more efficient i need to be
more productive
and we think the solution is that
something we need to do to work harder
and we do that we just end up exhausted
and still out of balance it didn't fix
the root issue
right and i i pretend i'm not a people
pleaser i for sure
am but i'm fascinated kristy and you can
help me with this i'm fascinated by
people
like your husband and my wife who i can
say hey we just got an invitation to
something in august
and she'll say we're gonna need to pass
on that and my first thought is
why it could be you don't like fun if
you don't like people why do you hate
america and
she'll say well we have 15 things going
on you've got this two weeks before
which
i'm around you during those seasons and
you're not right
i don't understand how somebody can look
at fun and think
what if we all slept think how much more
fun we would have if we just all ate all
of our meals right i don't understand
how somebody gets there and i do this
for a living
um but this is the one elusive thing for
me is
i pretend throughout a day that i can
just make more time i think that's what
it comes we all think that
yeah i live in a fantasy world yeah we
all do that and then what's interesting
is
instead of cutting things out or saying
no like
our spouses are better at than we are um
we try to run faster and then what
happens is
things drop and then we feel guilty and
i'm curious your thoughts on this
because what i found john and this is
certainly from personal experience
but also from years of working with
people men and women experience it
differently but we both
experience it there is such a layer of
guilt that factors into how we manage
our time
how we make decisions and even how we
feel balance what that even means to us
because i've noticed that we don't know
what balance is we're just sure we don't
have it
yeah and so it feels like we're chasing
a moving target it feels like we're
always guilty no matter what we do
it feels like it's the wrong thing and
so i'm curious your
you know your experience even with this
idea of like guilt and this nagging
feeling of like
gosh i can't get it together gosh i just
feel like i'm always doing the wrong
thing like
do you see that in people that you work
with oh yeah that's such a piece of this
and myself because i don't have
when i don't take the time to reverse
engineer my day or my week or my month
meaning i've got to have a picture of
what enough is
and i've got to have a picture of a day
well lived is
otherwise i'm always well i should
probably do this i'll probably do this
and i had a great day with my son
yesterday and so what did i do i went
home
and thought you know what i need oh he
wanted to read these books and so there
i'm on amazon there was no need to do
that
right um but i didn't have a picture of
what enough was today yeah and so i got
caught up in the man we had a great time
we were running around in the creek
being silly
i just want to keep this thing going
right yeah that's me i think that now
that i'm saying it out loud i'm that kid
at two o'clock in the morning and i'm
like
come on man let's just keep the lights
going like it's so dumb i'm tired i want
to sleep and
um but i think we don't have a good
understanding what a finish line is
on anything yeah and um so we just
run around untethered all the time yeah
we don't know what success looks like
and so we always feel like we're a
failure right and so i think that's a
big piece of it and
um it's funny you your book redefining
anxiety
when when we were coming out this book i
was like what about redefining balance
like no delony has the redefining titles
like okay we'll come up with something
else but what i love about the title we
landed on
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance because i don't think
this is just a time issue or a schedule
issue i think it's a heart issue
of this guilt piece of it and if we
don't fix our time problem at the root
level it's going to keep coming up
again and again and again and so i love
how
how you talked about that for any of you
guys listening right now and you need
help with managing your time
give us a call we're taking your calls
today me and dr john deloney
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
we're focusing on life balance time
management
managing anxiety and of course we're
always here to take your money
questions it'll be funny to see what
answers john and i come up with we're
gonna reveal it
it's gonna be so great we totally got
this this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you
make the most out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
i'm christy wright sitting in the chair
today with me
is dr john delony and we are taking your
calls
phone lines are open triple eight eight
two five
five two two five we talked last segment
about my book launching take back your
time so if you've got a time question
today's a great day to talk about it
we all struggle with having enough time
i certainly feel like that
hey so tell me about tell me about what
a book launch looks like
i'm in the middle of writing and i know
there's not a lot of sleep and there's
not a lot of
balance there's a lot of interviews you
get this thing out and now
now what's happening well this was funny
i was on an interview this morning
and uh it was like well what is what
does your schedule look like right now
i'm like
the the opposite of whatever you think
it is for someone that launched a book
on balance i'm like
i'm living and breathing but really
that's the reason that i love helping
figure out people figure out what's
right right now
because you can't do everything all the
time so figure out what's right right
now and do that right now
it's getting the book out there and
there's gonna be a season this summer
i've been playing a lot
and now we're switching gears so uh
phone lines are open triple eight eight
two five five two two five taking your
calls
about your life and your money dr john
deloney and i
are here to help we're to go to the
phones we've got a call from yadira in
bakersfield california
hey adira how's it going hi thank you so
much for taking my call i can't imagine
two better people to answer my question
i agree
i don't know your question is yes okay
so it's a two-part question
um so part one i have a wonderful
husband
i have a ton of dogs keep life
interesting i have an incredible talent
of succeed in everything i do
and i've done that by creating two
businesses
but i still find myself lacking and
finding myself really depressed and
lonely when i logically understand
that i'm super lucky and very blessed
and should not feel that way
but i do tend to feel empty and sad and
find it hard to get out of bed some days
and it's kind of just the circles around
the what's the point mentality
and then part two is because i want to
feel balanced
and accept things i don't have control
over and be able to feel happy when
happy
when good things happen i signed up for
better help on
john's referral link and i wanted to
know how i can make the most out of this
program i currently
was assigned a therapist i just spoke to
her once she seems really nice
but i want to determine if she is a good
fit and what i can do
or what i can request to help this
process be more helpful and beneficial
i've never gone to therapy and i've been
raised around people who don't believe
that therapy can help
so when i saw that you could do it
remotely i was super excited i just want
to know the best way to approach it
so i was just writing down what you're
talking
where does this story come from that you
are your achievement and you are the
amount of accomplishments you have and
you are the amount of
luck that you feel like you've received
from the world and then you ended this
with
i come from a family didn't believe in
therapy so then i thought well that
answered
that question somebody told you that
somebody either modeled that for you or
told you that directly that all your
dreams would come true
and when i say dreams i don't mean money
or jobs or anything i mean the ability
to sleep at night
the ability to hug your husband or hold
hands with him when you're going for a
walk
in it to feel like you can be there
instead of wondering about an email
that's come right you could be present
who told you that where'd that come from
um i think that just came
over um over a long period of time
so when i was younger i had a lot of
difficulties
um really just getting by day to day and
as i've gotten older i've just noticed
that
you know i i try to start a business it
goes great i try to start a project it
goes fantastic
anything that i ever tried in the last
few years i've noticed that i succeed at
and i hear that from my husband's family
specifically that they're so
surprised that i can do anything i say
i'm going to do it they might think i'm
crazy and i just do it
and so i it might come more from my
husband's family than my own
where that confidence comes from
christie you talked to a lot of i'll
challenge that in a second here but i
want to get back to
starting a business christa you talk to
a lot of folks who start businesses
um do you hear often that people get to
the end of it and think
and well i think i think there's uh
what well it's interesting because i you
know i put some research in my book on
um
even something as simple as like to-do
lists like the dopamine that's released
when you check a box
so i think there's an there can be and
i'm not i'm not the doctor here so you
tell me if i'm wrong but i think there
can be
in my life that i've experienced an
addictive nature of success and
achievement so you achieve something
it's like well what's next so i run a
half marathon i'm gonna do the full math
you become addicted to that achievement
well what how can i push myself and
there's part of that that i think is a
good quality but i think it can be
something like
i definitely have experienced that john
like i've experienced that where it's
like okay what's next
what's next yeah so ediro why are you
doing this
why are you going to therapy why are you
making creating successful businesses
why are you married to a great guy
um i don't know that's kind of the
reason that i'm
i'm really looking for answers so to
speak because but listen that is the
answer
if you are doing this for nothing for
achievement's sake it will always be
a vortex it'll be a black hole you'll be
jeff bezos you'll have 8 trillion
dollars
and then you'll think well i guess i'm
just going to quit and go to space
because i don't have anything else to do
right because what's next and i guess i
do it for like the stability i think i
think that's what what i'm looking for
and what i would tell you is stability
is an illusion
it feels good but it's never enough
and so you have to define this and it
sounds cliche and we talk about all the
time
you've got to have a thing you're doing
this for
or to say it in a nerdy way you gotta
have a why
and when you just spin and spin and spin
here's the deal
you have been running you've been fight
or flight for probably your whole life
and you can't out chi you can't
outperform you can't run
from a feeling of i don't have any value
or you can't run from a feeling of
um we don't have enough around here and
so
when you come up with enough number
that's what i love what dave talks about
you need to see six months
for an emergency fund and then we're
gonna say good man we don't have a
meteorite plan
right and so we have six months
emergency fund and then we're gonna move
on to the next thing
because if you keep spinning out your
wheels there then what are you gonna do
eventually your body says why you can
get out of bed
just go to bed just stay here and so
what i would love to challenge you
and your husband to do is to get away
from all the
the mess and by the way you're going to
start a business
and it's not going to be successful and
you know what that's going to be okay
you're still going to be here it is and
you're gonna have another one that's
successful another one after that's
successful great that doesn't define you
right it's cool and it's neat and we'll
high-five you
doesn't come from your your in-laws
they're just celebrating you right
um right it comes from this idea that
you think you can
outrun change and you can outrun
insecurity and you can't
you got to sit with it and let it be
present and feel it and it's
uncomfortable and it's awful
and you won't feel like you're enough
and then
as you talked about you go sit with
somebody who's a professional here's the
best thing you can do with the counselor
is to tell the truth
most people lie that's one of the first
things in grad school they teach you is
your
your clients will lie to you go tell the
truth okay tell the truth be honest
about your feelings about
what you do want to do what you don't
want to do and go somewhere with your
husband and you all sit down and say why
are we doing this
what do we want to be where we want to
go christy and i talking about earlier
about
reverse engineering what enough looks
like
what does are after we paid off our
house and after everyday millionaires
and after
what are we doing get to the
why to what you're doing the where you
want to be and reverse engineer it and
then
live a life that you love to live right
otherwise you can be running
and running and running and running and
then you're gonna be like well i guess
i'll just go to space for the weekend
because i don't know what else to do
right i think it kind of feels like that
it does it does and we can't go to space
because we have trillion dollars so we
just stay in bed and watch netflix right
right i think that'd be a great exercise
for you to
take on um you know with your counselor
yadira of this idea of discovering
what your why is and it may not happen
in one session it may not happen in just
one
five-minute prayer of being alone but if
you spend some time and dig
and dig like what makes you light up
what makes you come alive what gives
meaning and purpose to your life
can coleman talk about this on his show
john dolonie talks about this in his
show i talk about different ways on my
show
but that is the that is the baseline for
everything
for every business for every
relationship for every
everything you do needs to have a
purpose you need to have
a why or else no matter what you do
you're gonna wake up the same sinking
feeling
like you don't have a purpose i bet you
do you just need to find it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt-free stage
charmin is with us hey sharman how are
you great how are y'all
good so you are on the debt-free stage
which means you
are debt-free i can't wait to hear this
story okay tell us first of all where do
you live
i live in graham north carolina okay
awesome and how much debt have you paid
off
on the program about 12 000. okay i
actually started
way more than that when i got out of
college about 11 years ago so it was
like
total about like 38. 38. okay awesome
um student loans are horrible uh yeah
that's what we hear and that's what we
teach okay how long did it take you um
on the program
two and a half total is about like 11ish
okay so cool but once i got on the
program it kind of went faster because
like the gazelle intense thing it gave
you kind of extra motivation like you
can do this here's ways to do it
sure yeah okay we'll we'll just go with
your totals just for fun just because it
sounds better 38 000 that's awesome
what's your range of income during that
time about 17 to about 26.
oh wow and mine's lower but i felt like
coming here even with the lower one
income that could help people like me
that don't make a lot to say i can do
this too absolutely
1 000 yes absolutely the most common
critique i hear is people say
oh it's easy when you make a hundred
thousand dollars to
well you make 17. it's not a critique
it's an excuse
it's the number one excuse yes and then
i got a new job so it kind of started
bumping up a little
but and jobs over time but like what do
you do for a living
um i was a chef yeah now i'm a
seamstress at a
uniform company which is actually great
because there's a lot of great benefits
and everything
yeah and so like this weekend i was off
automatically and i got time off here
easily so
awesome got to come here and meet y'all
yeah cause i've been binge watching john
deloney's
or listening to it that is what i hear
it's like netflix very few people who
say that out loud so i appreciate you no
that's a compliment you like
helped me in ways you didn't even know
well i appreciate it that's awesome
that's awesome okay so sherman let's
talk about this debt the 38 000 let's
just do the whole amount here
what type of debt was this college okay
medical
care and bed oh bed okay
got a loan on the bed i got it yeah okay
and
it was it was kind of supposed to be
like half and half when i was married
and then a couple months after we bought
that i like the state fair
like split up so it was in my name so it
became mine so it's kind of good because
i got to keep it but i had to pay it
yeah so it kind of became like a love
hate thing and when i got my car it was
like a
love hate thing like i don't like it
because i don't like the debt but
i got it yeah yeah it all was a part of
it how much of the um
38 000 was college 26. uh what was your
what's your degree in
culinary arts and food service
management i wanted to own a restaurant
until i got into restaurants and
oh that has a stressful hard life yeah
people burn out really quick yes yes
yeah
i hear that a lot because it's like the
idea of like oh a chef that sounds so
cool and the reality is
nights and weekends and late nights and
you come home smelling like food and
you're like maybe not
everyone's just mean to you it's not
quite what you think when you watch it
on food network
yeah it's not it's not quite like that
and i thought i always wanted to have a
family and i thought if i'm owning a
restaurant i can't have a family one day
if i do i won't see them yeah so if you
think of it differently you know john i
wanted to be an event planner in college
and my mom told me she was like
uh you think about that because events
are on the weekends and if you have a
family and a
spouse that works nine to five you need
to think through the implications so it
does take some
some thinking through that okay so so
let's go back to
how did you decide to start paying this
off 11 years ago and then what happened
when you how are you introduced to us so
give us both
both stages of the story here so when i
came home from college and i was living
with my parents
and about the six months later when
everything started coming in
my dad set me down and i was like i
don't know how i'm going to do this
and he actually taught me the dave
ramsey way of paying them off because i
had like seven or eight different
individual
loans so you taught me pay them all pay
you know as much as you can on the the
least one
and then just keep adding so i did that
and i was making small progress but then
i got in more debt
so then i had to add that to it so i
just kept doing it the dave ramsey way
sometimes i just didn't realize it but
like i said when i got to dave ramsey it
just kind of escalated
and i was like before i knew it i was
like i'm going to be able to do this a
lot faster i can have an end date now
yeah yeah it lights a fight on fire
under you doesn't it yeah all right so
talk about the journey who were your
biggest cheerleaders in this journey
they were so my cousins right here they
gave me it
so i bought total money makeover and
when i did it was
right before i started my new job and i
was like i don't know if i should be
spending this money to get these two
books because of the workbook but i was
like
i'm just gonna do it and got a new job
and then it was about new year's eve day
um right the day before i started my new
job they told me well
you find a class for pfu and we'll pay
for it and
honestly i was like no they're not going
to do that when they left she texted me
she's like
yeah when you find your class to talk to
him we'll pay for it
i actually didn't find a class until
almost a year later
but i took it and i loved it
and then a year later yeah about
this this year actually i led the class
and then my parents took it and my
my mom had the whole dave ramsey curse
word thing in the house she
every time i said something about dave
ramsey she's like i don't want to hear
it
i don't i don't want to hear it and then
she wanted to support me and they wanted
to support me so they took it and now
they're doing stuff this
the program they're working on it so
they're my main ones and my brother
okay um he's home he's a firefighter so
he's got
crazy schedules but he he follows the
program too so um
they're my biggest ones i love it well i
know they are so proud of you
they have it's incredible to see the
different stages of your journey and
just how you stuck with it even with a
couple setbacks you stuck with it and
now
here you are debt free well i got to
tell you sharma we have got a copy of
the legacy journey for you
because that's definitely your next step
of the journey and of course we're going
to give you a copy of the total money
makeover you can gift that to a friend
another family member someone you can
help kick start their journey and get
them on the same
path that you are on and john and i are
so excited for you and we're so
so proud of you so um yeah i have two
little stories that i wanted to tell
that was okay
we actually have to go into them and we
need to get this debt free screen which
are going to be so good okay
charman is with us from greensboro north
carolina paid off 38
000 in 11 years making a range of income
of 17 to 26 000
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
way to go charmin gosh here's the thing
john that the debt-free journey is such
a long one that it's like
it's just amazing when you stand there
it's this milestone it's this i'm never
going back
my life has changed it never gets old to
see that never and
i hope anyone listening to this whether
you have a hundred fifty thousand
dollars
in debt or ten thousand twenty thousand
it's all on a scale and some people
think i don't have that much and it's
all good it's not
yeah people think i have too much i'm
not even gonna bother it's not
yeah right right sherman didn't make an
excuse
she didn't make a ton of money
everyone's i don't even know
you do yeah you have to have his people
in your corner and you got to have the
will power to wake up one day and say no
more i'm done
well it's such a simple concept that is
easy to understand but difficult to do
where you truly have to live on less
than you make stop crazy stop
what whether you make
or 700.000 000 you have to live on less
than that
in order to be able to afford your
lifestyle and certainly even less than
that if you're going to pay off this
debt and sharmon did it and i just think
it's incredible to see people
that have got the gusto to go for it
11-year journey in her case
and like you said on that income
sticking with it getting different jobs
she has made it and um and that is just
incredible i know there's a lot of
people listening right now
and they are going to find hope in that
and maybe the kick in the pants that
they needed
because maybe they don't have a big
income thinking okay i don't have an
excuse
i can actually do this and if you've
been through it just like her cousins
did
aunt and uncle cousins yeah
man sponsor somebody that you love yeah
you could change their entire family
tree
they were probably trying to get to your
parents and not to you
but they they got to you through the
like whatever it works
that one little investment has changed a
family tree for everybody
man find somebody in your life that you
can reach out and say you know what i'm
going to bless you with this we're going
to change everything for you starting
today
and uh fpu is a good way to get going
man that's why we do
what we do this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is dr john dolone we're taking your
calls
about life and money triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we've got a call from andrew in phoenix
arizona hey andrew how's it going
hey john christie how are you good
what's going on how can we help
hey so a little bit of background my
wife and i are debt-free
and then about two weeks ago my wife
found out that she is pregnant
oh congratulations thanks and then
additionally i'm making the jump to get
out the army next year
so my question is what are some wise
financial goals during this time
because right now it just kind of feels
like every time i spend takes away from
the baby or
money we need to transition out of the
army yeah how much savings do you have
um we have a three-month emergency fund
that we're beefing up to a six
and then that's our main goal right now
yeah so what money are you feeling
guilty about spending
um a great question i think
uh most of it my wife's also uh
part-time or full-time in grad school
and so we're cash flowing back so it
just kind of feels like every time we do
our
uh budget i've been using every dollar
like past six years so like every time
we do our budget it just kind of feels
like
the numbers always come up short do you
is this your first kid
okay um chrissy you can
tell me if i'm crazy here um i remember
planning for my first child
and i over guilted and over dramatized
and over
scrutinized everything so if you were
telling me that
yeah bro i'm like getting my jeep extra
jacked up right now
and i'm like doing some knucklehead
things like that then
i want to buy a boat and i would tell
you yeah you should feel guilty about
that right now if it's not in your
budget y'all haven't planned for it if
you can't afford it
and you've got a new baby coming on the
way if you've got a budget
and you are doing quote unquote normal
things like investing in grad school and
you're cash flowing you're doing
everything
right then high five to you man your
guilt i would pass along christy hop in
here
your guilt is at least in my experience
is a normal part of
prepping for the great unknown which is
what is my life gonna look like after a
kid and so i get apprehensive and i get
anxious and so then i just
never feel like i'm on firm footing
andrew quick question about the
transitioning from the army
have you run the numbers on that like
how much are you making what will you be
making
what is that going to look like from an
actual tangible number standpoint
um i haven't sat down and like actually
run the numbers like on a piece of paper
but i have a general idea
i think the hard part is that i want to
do uh my own thing whether it's a
financial coaching business or just
something on my own that doesn't feel
very practical right now because i don't
have
any real plan in that direction yeah so
here's what i would recommend and this
is a really simple answer but i think
this will help relieve some of your
fears and hopefully some of your guilt
you're already using every dollar for a
regular monthly basis
but it sounds like you've got several
things going on in your life
two at least if not potentially three
that are completely unknown
and so what you want to do is you want
to put numbers to those things as much
as you can like okay
i'm making up hypotheticals here andrew
but let's say if i have six months of
emergency fund i will feel secure about
bringing
about bringing the baby home with a
six-month emergency fund if i have x
amount of dollar
you know i'm making this and i'm gonna
be making this in this period of time
there's two months in between three
months
this is how much money i need i'm gonna
set this aside putting some numbers
goals to these unknowns
i think will relieve some of your fear
and then it gives you permission to put
line items on the budget for the things
that you need and the need
the amount that you want because you go
oh i'm covered right now it's just a lot
of question marks
and that is scary the unknown ambiguity
that that makes anybody feel anxious and
nervous because it's like i don't know
how much do i need i don't know how much
for the baby i don't know how much to
transition jobs i don't know for the
business i don't know
so i just want to encourage you take
these one thing at a time step
one the baby's coming you know when
roughly
let's just set a number to it if it's
five months emergency fund six months
average fund whatever that amount of
money is
then when you get it give yourself
permission to relieve the fear there as
much as you can within reason i know
you've got emotions around it but you
know okay i've got the money
transitioning from the army run some
numbers how much money do you need to
make this transition what will you be
making in what amount of time
and then if you want to do your own
thing that's fine it may just we're just
not gonna do it all the same time
yeah it's gonna be priority one priority
two priority three with numbers attached
with timelines attached and i think if
you do that andrew
i think that will relieve your fear and
overwhelm because even when those
emotions rise up like anybody does when
they're transitioning jobs
or bringing a baby home because that's a
that's a crazy time you at least have
the numbers on paper to say
we're okay is that do you think that
would happen i mean that's
100 100 that's going down to the very
basic what can you control here
right um yeah andrew you you can't start
your new coaching job right now
you don't have enough clients you don't
have people you got a new baby you're
gonna have to get an interim job
and like you said put the paper put the
numbers on the paper you wouldn't go
into combat without doing
the appropriate reconnaissance and
budgeting what tools do you need
same situation here right yeah we um one
of the things that's funny
the correlation between time and money
is just so um
it's kind of incredible because i think
that we put pressure on ourselves maybe
from desire maybe from outside pressures
to do everything all the time and we
want to do everything all the time with
our time and we would do everything all
the time with our money
they're both mythological right yeah and
we we feel spread
thin and then it removes our ability to
focus
and gain traction in any one area and so
one of the questions i've been asking
myself lately and it's in relation to
time since we've been talking about this
a
lot
but i say what is right right now what
is right right now with my time
what is right right now with my money
okay what's right right now i have a
baby coming home for example in andrew's
case
what is right right now in a year maybe
that's the business
but you prioritize and i think so much
of our stress john
comes from and i know women are really
bad about this we treat everything as if
it's created equal and it's not
so when push comes to shove two things
need us whether it's with time or money
we don't know how to make decisions
because we have lost the ability to
prioritize and say this
is first most important this is second
most important this is third most
important and so on and so i think if if
you can put on paper
what is most important in order of
priority
and create some goals around that
whether it's just a deadline or a dollar
amount it doesn't matter
it relieves your fear and it also gives
you permission to say hey just because
i'm not going to start a business right
now doesn't mean never
no it just means it's not right right
now right you've got a
wife in grad school and you've got to
finish the year in the army and you're
going to have to earn an income
right now because you got a little kit
right right so it's not the season
yeah but you will be working towards it
and i'll tell you um
i i've never heard somebody explain it
that way but i love what you just said
that
women often flatten things out and say
it's all important right now
um guys run around and keep a lot of
crap in their head
and i'll i'll get to it i'll get to it i
was talking about earlier about
i was anxious when beforehand was born i
didn't know it you had never occurred to
me like an
idiot it never occurred to me just to
sit down with somebody who had a kid and
said hey how much the diapers cost how
much does food
what an arrogant [ __ ] this is not a
mystery we can find it out
and it's it's everywhere as an answer
because everyone i know has
kids yet i spent i thought my worry
energy my ruminating energy my
i don't know i don't know i should
google it look at it i thought that was
time and thoughts well spent because
they felt
important and impactful and god almighty
dude it would have taken a
half an hour on a spreadsheet right to
say oh it costs about this and across
about that
right and that's about what you're gonna
need and i would have gone huh oh okay
you know what i mean watch out just
putting it on paper and that's why we
teach people to do a budget yeah but
it's the same thing
with your calendar whatever it is it's
just a plan if you want to run a
marathon you've got a plan
on paper and when you have a plan when
you can see it
you can do it it's when you try to keep
it in your head
that that's when it starts to create the
worry and create the anxiety i think
david allen in his book getting things
done said
your mind is for having ideas not
holding ideas yes and that's what keeps
you up at night
and it's it's you just it's a budget
it's calendar
it's also with your thoughts right just
taking a moment
in the day to say i'm gonna write this
down real quick hold on i've got 50
things spinning
does she really not like me is that why
this no
she does like this stuff going on right
it's just write this stuff down yeah
that's so good well in case you guys
need help
with your time my new book take back
your time the guilt-free guide to life
balance
is available for pre-order today get it
when you get your copy you know what
we've got all kinds of fun stuff for you
guys you get the audiobook free
the ebook free you get a ticket to my
event in september for free and you get
access to a private facebook group with
me
for free get your copy of take back your
time
the guilt-free guide to life balance i
want to help you spend your life
on what is most important
congratulations
on that thank you thank you i want to
thank producers james child associate
producer kelly daniel my
co-host dr john dolone this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright i'm a
business coach and author
and i'm joined today by dr john dalone a
best-selling author you
are you left that up conveniently thank
you john and this is a big
big big day for you this is a big day my
new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance is available for
pre-order which means you get the e-book
the audiobook
you get a ticket to my live event in
september all for free when you get your
copy early
and john you know i've been asked this
morning a couple times on interviews
earlier
um you know how long i've been working
on this message and
it sounds dramatic which i can be
dramatic but this is not a dramatic
answer
it's truly been almost a decade in the
sense that this was one of the first
things i was ever booked to speak on
back years ago before i ever had kids
before i was even married
it's such a pain point in our culture
and even more so now
than it was ten years ago with social
media you've got a phone in your pocket
screaming your name
24 hours a day the demands are unending
and so you know everywhere i go uh
entree leadership events
business boutique events outside
speaking events i'm always
asked the question how do you balance it
all how do you balance it all and it's
interesting because i saw an article
and i was going to ask you about this
your thoughts on this so
um when i'm asked about this topic i'm
always asked
where balance is a verb how do i balance
it all and we've got all the analogies
right like spinning plates and juggling
balls and some balls are rubber and some
balls are glass and which balls can you
let break and walking in tightrope and
all of those things feel very
i just threw up in my mouth like six
times just when you just said that no
that was graphic it feels like that is
exhausting full of anxiety and
doesn't guarantee you're gonna have
balance i can do all of that i can
juggle all the balls spin all the plates
and i still
may not feel balance and so it led me to
a different question what if balance
isn't so much something you do
how you balance it all perfectly but
instead something you create
where it looks more like peace it looks
more like
i feel confident my choices or i'm
actually happy
with how i spend my time and it's
interesting because this
term work-life balance is one of those
things that
people have a visceral response to like
it's very emotionally charged it's very
triggering some people roll their eyes
some people scoff at the word oh it
doesn't exist
and i saw this article uh recently it
says jeff bezos
says work-life balance is a debilitating
phrase
interesting i mean his take on is
interesting in the article but there's a
there's a
sentence in here that i wanted to ask
you about because it quotes him and it
says
it's actually a circle bezos said it's
not a balance
he says he doesn't compartmentalize his
career in his personal life now here's
one of the things i've seen
in researching this topic for a decade
and living it and teaching it and so on
we have a lot of alternative phrases
it's not work life balance it's work
life harmony
it's not work life balance it's work
life integration it's not work life
balance it's a
circle here's what here's the thing i
just do up in my mouth again
i i get it i get i get people trying to
provide an alternative
to the word but here's what i would say
that still doesn't provide a solution
telling me that it's a circle does not
help me
feel better about how i spend my time
and so
john what it really you know what i
unpack in the book um
is life balance isn't doing everything
for an equal amount of time
it's about doing the right things at the
right time and when you do the right
things at the right time you feel that
sense of balance you've been looking for
whether the right things are being all
in at work for that season or that week
or that day
all in with your kids on vacation taking
care of your health taking care of a
parent
none of us can do everything all the
time and when we put that pressure on
ourselves of course we feel guilty
but if we can identify what the right
things are and do the right things at
the right time
giving yourself permission to change as
those change by season by week by day
then you can feel that sense of balance
and what i mean by that is peace
you can feel confident like hey i feel
good about how i'm spending my time but
i'm not doing
everything but it gives me permission to
say all those no to all those things
that are not right right now
like we were talking about earlier what
are your thoughts on this phrase
it's not about balance it's a circle
yeah
i my immediate response is um
i'm i'm trying not to swear and i'm
trying not to get
it's always a good start um going back
to what you said
everything starts with intentionality
and somewhere along the way
um and it's been brewing for years and
years we were told by our
family systems and by our culture and by
our teachers when we were
my son was was being asked about what
college is going to go to in first grade
right
it's just it's part of the um
intellectual economy
which is there will never be enough and
you can do all of it
at the same time and that's what success
looks like and then you hand everybody a
computer in your pocket that
curates all this and makes it look
perfect right um
and i think it goes back to that one
magic word which is intentionality
and what you said is some seasons um
my wife and i sit down and say it's
gonna be a we did that last night
this week is a bonkers week for us for
me
at work and we have guests coming here's
what this week's gonna look like for us
next week i'm on vacation so we're gonna
have six days
my kids are involved in that and so i'm
not going to feel this sense of guilt
because i'm not
right but it comes back to
intentionality everyone will be on the
same page when i see something like this
it usually comes from ceos and my first
thought is one of
well that's really easy to to
think about your life in a circle when
you are
um not worried about whether you're
gonna have enough food right when you're
not working three jobs trying to put
stuff on the table when you're not when
you're not when you're not
um it's so fun to think of life in
shapes
yeah you're not hungry right and i know
that's i i i don't wanna i don't know
jeff he's probably a great guy
um i do think that it's easier to think
about your life in this big
as a big dance when you're
working towards a mission that you love
and you're connected to everything and
it all feels good and then your friends
or folks that you work with that's all
fine and good i just work and you work
with millions of people
who are just sleeping in boxes all day
and then they uber at night and then in
the mornings they're
you know trying to get their thing off
the ground and life isn't a circle man
it's a
grind yeah well and you make a good
point because everybody's
not only their seasons are different
their families are different their works
different the demands they have on them
are different but i think what's
frustrated me
in this journey with um this topic
specifically which i love a good
challenge which is why i took this on
but it's one of those things where it
just frustrates me when it still doesn't
solve the problem you can give me all
the analogies of juggling balls spinning
plates walking a type rope you can give
me all the shapes in the world
integration harmony
circles triangles i i don't care
if it doesn't solve the problem i have
in my life then it doesn't help me
so what is the problem is the problem
that it's it's an
it's a dishonest standard
i i think that one no i think that when
we say we don't have balance
we might be saying i work too much we
might be there's a percentage of people
that are saying that but i think what a
lot of people are saying is
something doesn't feel right i'm not
fulfilled i don't have joy in my life i
feel and i feel guilty that's why i made
the tagline the guilt-free guide to life
balance because i think guilt is a big
piece of this
but i truly believe and i have
experienced this and i've coached people
through this
when you do the right things at the
right time you feel that sense of
balance and you shake the guilt and it
does
actually solve that problem that you
thought you had of
always feeling like you're coming from
behind never having balance but it's not
in the way that we think it's a
different approach somebody wrote a
bullcrap free
book about taking back your time and
getting balance
great for you thank you ramsay
solutions.com you can get your copy and
pre-order today
this is the ramsey show
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
how many of y'all are stressed out or
hurting because your retirement savings
took a major hit last year
maybe you were super close to retiring
and now you're wondering if you should
work a few more years to make up the
difference
maybe you weren't investing in the right
things or you were investing
aggressively and you lost more than you
could stomach
maybe you pulled everything out and now
you're wondering where you should go
from here listen
if you're in one of these situations i
want you to know you don't have to face
this pain alone
now more than ever is the time to seek
out the advice of an investment
professional a conscientious of
investment pro like one of our smart
vester pros is not going to tell you to
invest in something dumb
like gold they're going to spend a ton
of time looking at your current
situation
and helping you create a plan to get
back on track
you don't have to let 2020 kill your
confidence in your retirement
go to dave ramsey.com smart vester and
find an investment pro in your area
never again face a global crisis alone
that's dave ramsey.com smart vester
and now we have got kelly in charlotte
north carolina hey kelly how's it going
i'm good how are y'all good how can john
and i help today
um i lost my husband about six months
ago after a
four-year long hard battle with cancer
oh i'm so sorry
i'm sorry um well the well the life
insurance money was enough to get out of
debt and
pay the house off and stuff i'm just
having trouble
getting excited about it just given
everything going on
yeah um and you know now the income as
well he was the breadwinner for the most
part so now our income has been slashed
two-thirds so even uh
you know live and give like no one else
is not
what it what we envisioned it to be
and um i was the dave ramsey one for
quite a while in our marriage up until
about the last two years of his life
and then he kind of got on board and we
got to pay off his truck he got really
excited about it
and then um he you know the cancer came
back full force so
i'm just wondering how to go about
re reshuffling my mind to kind of
grab hold of this and to
get excited when it's been such a long
hard goal of mine for a long time yeah
first and foremost i'm i'm so sorry
sounds like this guy was
he's incredible huh he was
truly he paid off his truck in
the middle of fighting for his life
and he cheered it on right yep what a
stop
and y'all got little ones too uh we have
a 19 and 22 year old
are not so little i'm the rents of the
family now
they're still little they're still
little um
so
okay i'm just gonna talk blunt with you
is that okay
yes sir okay um you're not gonna get
excited about this
okay there's no there's no your debt
free screen will be very very different
the cheer will be very very different
because you're going to be doing it
alone
and this was something y'all set out to
do together this was a co-adventure
for y'all's family tree and um
man he got you all the way down the
finish line handed that baton off
and you cross the finish line by
yourself right
and so yeah um it's not going to be that
cheer it's not going to be that
excitement
now you can come down to nashville and
do your debt-free screen we will cheer
and scream with you it'll be a moment of
joy and jubilation but it's gonna
look different and it's gonna feel
different okay
so i don't want you to spend another
second of energy
trying to muster up some kind of fake
confetti in your heart that's not there
this was supposed to be the two of you
and it's just you and that's
heartbreaking and it's sad and that's
what grief is right
um there is the reality that you've got
this money
and you've got these bills right is this
house a house that you want to stay in
um for the time being i have a son in
college so i want to stay there at least
until he graduates in three years okay
is there a big
rush to pay it all off or is that
something you just want to do for your
own security
um the rush is just in the fact that i'm
now
my income has taken such a hit so
the monthly mortgage payment is not in
the budget you know
the 25 and all that sure
so um at some point you might
you know you're six months in is for all
intents and purposes this is still just
as brand new and as real as it was
four months ago and five months ago
right so there's a level of healing
and healing does doesn't mean you're not
going to hurt and healing doesn't mean
that you're not going to miss this guy
every single day especially a guy as
awesome as this
healing means you're going to be able to
talk about it and your eyes won't well
up on you right healing means you're
going to smile when you think about the
good stuff
right and that's still months and months
months ahead
if paying off the house and getting out
of debt and clearing that up with that
money and you're able to take care of
college stuff if you're able to do those
things that's going to buy you a year or
two of financial piece so you
can then begin to think what i want to
do with my career what i want to do for
the back half of my life how old are you
i'm 54. 54. yeah you're you're just
halfway done yourself
right so you got all kind of adventures
ahead of you it will give you some space
and some time to think through it
if you're gonna sell this house in six
months then i would tell you don't pay
it off
hang on to it right get out of your
consumer debt and hang on to the
mortgage
and take a withdraw and pay it off that
way but if you're going to stay there
for three years four years five years
then yeah pay it off and get some people
that you love and you care around you
and you all celebrate this with a prayer
you'll celebrate this with a
some hugs and some tears but it will
look very very different and then when
you're ready we're gonna have a spot for
you here in nashville
so you can come to your debt free scream
on our stage yeah and kelly
the only thing that i would i would add
because i just i love how john
highlighted that it's not going to be
exciting
i would just i would just encourage you
and just affirm
take the pressure off that it should be
it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be exciting this
money represents something you never
wanted to happen
and um and you can still move forward
and use it how you and he wanted to use
it
but take the pressure off that you
should feel a certain way
act a certain way experience this a
certain way
um i just i love how john highlighted
that that that is
that is perfectly okay for you to give
yourself what you need
in this season to grieve and to move
forward
one step at a time and we'll be thinking
about you kelly thank you for calling in
john i have you seen
people experience when they're going
through a season i know you've worked
with a lot of people in
different types of trauma and heartbreak
where they feel a pressure to experience
it a certain way
or to act a certain way or respond a
certain way and kind of wrestling
through that
yeah everybody thinks that they know how
they would react when
there's a car wreck or there's a thing
or if what would happen it
in the realities you don't know and
that's why it's so important to have
people around you
because you think you've got i'm gonna
do it like you don't have any idea
you know what i mean so um that's why
it's important that people bring food
and that's why it's important that we'll
have people that will spend the night
with you sleep on your couch and make
sure your
pets are eating and your kids are eating
stuff so um
but over six months seven months 10
months so everybody does this
differently
cancer is different than car wrecks and
car wrecks are different than
you know sudden you know mild
everything's different
um you begin to
think what's my new picture going to
look like right what's tomorrow going to
look like i get to craft this and create
it and i didn't plan on it but this is
the way this is and
friends and community members and a good
church member or
a counselor can walk you through what's
it like to dream again because i've only
dreamed with
this other person right what's this new
thing going to look like and
don't move and be my grandkids or do i
want to start a new job all those things
look different and they feel different
what we don't often think christie is
that those are things we practice
right and they are the things you
practice and stumble around into and
that's what again
that's what people are so important for
yeah and i love how um
you know i've hosted with um dave ramsey
before and he always talks about not
making
any major financial decision if you can
help it
yeah six months to a year after the
event because
you can't think clearly you know even if
it costs you a little bit more
in interest or something just give
yourself the space to grieve
to be present to give yourself what you
need and um
and to to be able to think clearly again
once the fog clears a little bit doesn't
mean it's going to be
easy and it doesn't mean you're ever
going to necessarily be excited about it
either let me say this blessings to this
family
for having a will and having life
insurance i've sat with people christy
who look at me and say
we got nothing i don't know what to do
now like they're gonna have to grieve at
work on monday because they don't have
any money
good for him if you don't have a will
get
a will get a will and take care of your
family after you're gone it is a
selfless thing you can do it's not fun
to talk about but you'll be so glad
everyone will be so glad you did
thanks for the call kelly this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm kristy wright and hosting with me
today is dr john dolone we're taking
your calls about your life
your money maybe you're dealing with
this financial situation you need some
advice on we're here for you maybe
you're just dealing with a decision
you've got to make
somewhere you're not sure if you should
say yes you should say no what you
should do maybe there's relationship
dynamics
john is so good at that we were just
talking even off air i was asking him
about some different things about
just conflict and and how you navigate
that and gosh it's so good to have an
outside perspective give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we're gonna go to grand rapids
michigan with toby hey toby how are you
hi guys i'm very blessed how you doing
great what's going on
good yeah so um i'm a small business
owner i've owned my business only a year
i'm only 25
i got a couple babies married of course
and my business just hasn't been doing
as great as i've been hoping
i do appliance repair and my question is
um
originally was if there is a seven baby
step
or seven step baby step program for
small business owners like myself
or if you guys have any help that you
can give me to help me
maybe advertise better for my business
to beat out competitors i don't know
it's just any
anything like that so yeah that's a
great question you know toby we've
actually had that exact conversation
uh among our leadership team here
between the entree leadership team
and my team with business boutique which
are a little bit different entree
leadership is more focused on
team development and small business and
then business boutique is primarily
women with you know startups and
inside businesses small businesses but
what's interesting is
the business journey while there are
some principles they're built on you
need a business plan
you need a model to make money you need
some basics uh it's not linear
like money you know it's not as linear
as baby step one baby step two so
i wanna just ask you a few more
questions about your business what
how long have you been in business how
much money are you making what are the
main problems you're seeing that are
keeping you from
uh being as successful as you want to be
i think you said it's not growing or not
doing as well as you want it to be kind
of um
give me some numbers and specifics
around what you're saying
yeah i had two appliance guys out to my
house this week
so we need you man what's the deal yeah
the business is
yeah i know i really appreciate it um
yeah so as far as how much i made i
believe my business did 36
last year that was actually at the
beginning of corona in
february take home i think my wife and i
took home i think
19 or 24 of that
it's just me working for the company the
issues that i'm running into is
in my area i just have um some big name
companies that i'm having to go against
and it's just me working for myself
just kind of uh i got good at what i was
doing i loved what i did i love people
and i love fixing things and this has
the best of both worlds
yeah um so i just pursued it and it's
there's a lot more to it than i thought
yeah so kind of just learning as i as i
go so i hope that answers your questions
that's great i'm gonna tell you a few
things that jump out already and you've
just given me a couple sentences
first question are you charging enough
and i want you to shoot me straight
toby are you charging enough
i would say i am on the cheaper end of
um businesses around me but i do that to
try and get more business
yeah yeah that that man it's so that's
such a
temptation
it actually kills me because here's the
thing you think
in your mind i've got to compete about
against these big name companies
what have i got to use well i'll just be
cheaper the problem is
a long list of problems number one
you're getting cheap clients because
you're pricing cheap it's like fishing
that's the bait you're putting out so
that's what you're catching
number two you're not making any money
and number three that's not a unique
value proposition that there's something
else that makes you unique
that is going to draw people to you that
is going to be so much stronger and more
compelling
and enable you to charge more and make
more money so
so when you say you're competing about
the the big names here's what's great
about this
because you're solopreneur because
you're a one-man show
you have all the opportunities in the
world to
decide what your brand is going to be
about and then build a brand around it
let me just give you some real basics
out of the gate toby that you can do
you can be the go-to guy that is always
on time
always does an outstanding job never
leaves the kitchen floor dirty
and by the way you could even be someone
that someone can get
tomorrow immediately because let me tell
you if my dishwasher is leaking
i don't want someone that's going to
come in three weeks i want them to come
today
or tomorrow right so if you start to
understand what are the pain points of
your audience that you can solve
that the big names are not solving they
come in they leave mud tracks they're
booked three weeks out they're late they
don't get
and then you begin to be the go-to guy
people will pay more
and they will tell everyone they know
which brings me to my second piece of
advice toby
and that is you have got to activate
referrals in your business
every single person that you do work for
leave them a stack of business cards and
say next time you need me you get 25
off for every person you send to me you
act this is a referral based business
that's your sweet spot because who i
want
teaching my kids to swim highlighting my
hair or fixing my appliances is someone
that my friends have used and trust
service based businesses yes it's a
referral
based business so just out of the gate
that's an initial thing
that you can do which is to decide what
are the things that are going to
differentiate you from the big guys and
it's not price
activate your referrals and charge more
and i promise you
when you charge more you will actually
get better clients
you will get better clients that are
willing to pay more that don't nickel
and dime you that don't pick you apart
you get better people i had a um
photographer in business boutique toby
that she was um under charging by too
much she actually tripled her prices and
she was so nervous
that she was going to lose all her
business and she lost a few of her
customers
but she ended up i'm sorry she doubled
her prices ended up tripling her amount
of revenue
because she got more customers at the
higher price point yes you'll lose some
of your cheapos and that's a good thing
you'll get better customers and probably
more customers and toby let me tell you
what i just experienced in my house let
me tell you i'm gonna tell you the good
stuff and the negative you ready
here's the good stuff they texted me and
my wife
a picture of who was coming they said
here's one time we're gonna be there and
they were
on time and then this was really cool
because i'm a guy i'm skeptical by
nature
somebody goes and tinkers around and
then they go hey it's 342
because you need a catalytic converter
whatever
windows 9.7 they actually took the part
out
took a photo of it and then they left
the part with me
they said hey this is what we changed
this is how i changed it and i wasn't
there but he explained it to my wife
i tell you i'm so appreciative i trust
the guy now
i trust him yeah here's what was a hard
thing i said hey while you're here
can you give me a quote on a hot water
heater and can you check this one thing
out
ah well our hot water heater divisions
are part of our plumbing part which they
they'll be here next
boo big company big company here's what
your answer to that is yep
i'll figure it out because you're a
solopreneur and your answer to those
things is yes and then the sec the last
thing is
as they left my wife was going to work
on something like some fencing issues
some silly thing and she said man
i wish we could just call one person
that could do all this stuff and i know
there's handymen everywhere and you're
an appliance guy but right now you need
to make more money
let's just cut you got to make more
money whether that's picking up lawns
whether that's
doing painting whether that's doing
fence repair stuff that may be a little
bit out of your scope
of service but that's going to make you
some money right now
and you're going to be top of mind so
that anybody needs anything they call
toby
that's right and then someday you're
going to have so much business and
making so much money that you'll be able
to say hey i've got a long division
they'll be here at 9 00 a.m right
or i love christmas i said you're the 27
36 24 7 365 guy
i'll be there late and you can do that
for three years and just suck it up and
you're gonna be tired but you're gonna
build your business as the on-call guy
whatever that looks like for you you
know what i mean um and you may even
reach out
to some of these big big guys and say
hey i'll be your on-call guy
in the middle of the night i don't know
if that works or not but um just
spreading the things spreading yourself
out all over the place and um
showing up there yeah it's toby i if you
do even one of these things that we
recommended
you're making more money yep if you do
all three or four that we recommended
you're making a lot more money but stay
on the line i'll have kelly sends you a
copy of business boutique yes it says
it's for women but listen the business
principles apply
you can read it in secret and not see
that before you're reading about it i
read it in a coffee shop
these business principles are literally
for building a solopreneur entrepreneur
business and that is what you're doing
and that will give you even more tips to
activate your referral base business
to understand what you're
unique selling proposition is what sets
you apart how to build your brand
what are you the go-to guy for figure it
out
leverage the heck out of it and then
you'll watch that business
grow great great question i hope that's
good i'm toby this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
today is an exciting day i'm
sitting here right next to her christy
wright national bestselling author and
ramsey personality
has been heads down on a project she's
been passionate about for a
long long time 10 years or so in the
making
because it deals with an issue that's
affected her personally
how to feel balanced in your life just
the way you phrase that christy
not how to be balanced but how to feel
balanced is
makes this book unique in the space we
were talking about earlier it's just
so full of nonsense people like life
balance life balance
just ride the pony or whatever it's like
a diamond
your heart shut up you wrote the right
book today we're launching the pre-sale
of her new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to
life balance this book was born out of
christie's real life struggles for years
she was running on empty and was
stretched way too thin
as a mom of three she realized something
had
to change she took a long hard look at
her life and her calendar
figure out why she felt overwhelmed and
over committed all the time
she discovered that balance is about
doing the right things
at the right time and drum roll please
you
get to decide what's right for you this
is not some lame productivity book or a
book on
just say no that was the 80s you'll
learn the step-by-step plan on how
how to be intentional with your time and
how to finally prioritize the things
that you really want
to do so they stop getting pushed to the
back burner time is like your money if
you're not intentional with it
it's going to leave stop living burned
out and actually feel
balanced which is another word for peace
go to the online store ramsey
calm and pre-order your copy of
christy's new book take back your time
today when you do you'll get over 50
bucks of free
bonus items congratulations christy big
day
big day i'm so excited for you thank you
for that
also like your version of the marketing
copy that involves a diamond in your
heart
and rainbow
i was like he's going all script and i
like it it's great
i just can't tell you how many times how
do you get work life balance well what
you got to do is nine somersaults in a
field of clover and what are you talking
about it's not helping me i mean i'll
tell you what we talked about this at
unter leadership summit but it's like
it's one of those things where it's like
i don't know balance is but i just know
i don't have it that's how most people
feel they don't know what it is but they
know they don't have it and i want to
help them
know what it is and know how to have it
you're so great i'm so glad you read it
i wrote it and i'm uh i'm gonna be one
of those people that reads their friends
books but here we go
thank you you should i hope you do all
right
going to san francisco we've got judy
hey judy how's it going
uh hey it's going okay what's up judy
how can we help how can we help
um take a breath home you can take your
time
my sister just got married um
june 11 and then just shy of her
what was the university
my brother-in-law um just suddenly died
in the house
oh no i'm so sorry
i'm thinking of either a massive heart
attack or
a brain aneurysm my birth and
this is the first time in our family
that we've ever had
this sudden unexpected loss um
i just want to know um how we can help
her
get yeah i'm so sorry judy
and she is lucky lucky lucky to have you
tell me about this guy
um his name's mike
only 35. was he a fun guy a silly guy
a grumpy guy he's a fun guy
[Music]
he had a he had some struggles growing
up but he
kind of turned his life around and for
my sister who was like
i feel like out of the guys that she was
with before he was the only one who kind
of like
was her equal and to match her
um it was just so fun and easy going and
totally non-judgmental yeah like it's so
easy to have a
conversation with him a guy that you
want your sister be married to huh
yeah for sure judy um
our hearts broken with yours and your
families and we'll be thinking about you
guys and praying
for you guys um right now you're gonna
be in a season
of disbelief and of
trying to get the next right thing done
which is often eating
which is often going outside and going
for a walk which is often sleeping and
making sure the light bill is paid
um we're all able to have a funeral
and everybody get to go
um yeah it's gonna be this thursday i'm
gonna it's
i'm gonna be flying out to the east
coast
good good good so if at all possible
make sure you don't miss that funeral
make sure
you're a part of that and a funeral is a
great way
to tell somebody that you love them that
you remember them
and um especially
as a way you can show your sister that
you love her
often and again i i everybody does grief
differently and so not judging your
sister not telling her she should be
doing this by now or that by now
you know it's about a week now so you
should not having any of that kind of
language
but just letting her know that you love
her if you can spend some time there
with her
if you can make sure that she's got
meals that are going to show up at her
house if you've got people that are
going to show up there with her
whenever the time comes that you gotta
start packing boxes and go through wills
and go through life insurance stuff
that she's got somebody there with her
that can walk along that side that and i
do this
for a living and if my wife suddenly
passed away i'd have somebody with me
because i know enough to know that i
wouldn't be clear doing that
the other thing is if she's got a job
and she doesn't have
emergency needs financially
there is no rush there is no rush
the guy who was important in my life
said
six six months to a year you take your
time man
um and then for you as sister texting
every day
checking in with her telling her that
you'll love her calling your mom and
make sure they're doing good if y'all
got other brothers and sisters but just
making sure everybody's talking and
communicating together
okay okay um and then there's when the
time comes
there is nothing worse than handing
somebody some cliche pillow
with a with a clever slogan on it or
handing somebody some book when they're
struggling right
um but over time two months five months
seven months
the book finding meaning by david
kessler i think is the masterpiece
on grief on how to think through what's
happening in your heart and head
when you've lost somebody close to you
and that might be something that you say
hey let's read this together
because you're struggling you're all
struggling everybody's struggling um
the main thing here is there's no right
way to do grief everybody does it
different
and there is no rush to do anything or
feel a certain way
this is just gonna hurt y'all are right
in the middle of it and i'm so so sorry
thank you i am glad she's lucky to have
you as a sister who's gonna go out there
and see her
okay so i want you to keep us um
let us know how the funeral goes um let
us know if there's anything else we can
do to help
and if your sister needs help figuring
out finances or what comes next or how
we
how she's gonna make sense of the next
six months next year next two years
tell her to give us a call back but
we're grateful for your heart judy and
we'll be thinking of praying about you
so sorry that happened john i like how
you pointed out that everyone does
grief differently because i think that
it gives people
permission and freedom to have grace for
themselves if it looks different than
how someone else does it or what they
thought it was going to look like and
and i think that that has got to be um
it
just so uh almost just a source of
comfort
in that season that knowing there's no
performance there's no formula there's
no playbook of like this is how it
should go
um because it's different for everyone
in every situation the last thing we
need to do is beat ourselves up because
more pressure on yourself yeah or
sometimes when folks don't know what to
do they want to help they don't know how
so they project on to people who are
hurting
hey you need to be doing this this and
this and this because that's them trying
to take control back which i get and
yeah
and i honor it but man the last thing
people often need is another set of
expectations
they do need to get up and they do need
to eat and they need to go exercise and
they do need to take showers and things
like that so there are some needs there
but this whole
you need to move on or somebody go find
somebody else or you need to get rid of
all the clothes
man that everybody does that differently
yeah and just yeah
just not underestimating for anyone
listening right now that has someone
going through a hard time and i'd be
willing to bet a lot of you do everybody
because a lot of people are going
through hard times
uh don't underestimate the value
in just being there show up your mouse
yeah sending a text saying how are you
i'm thinking about you how are you i'm
bringing you dinner tonight
how are you i'm coming over a few
minutes to you know hang out
to just be there just sit yeah so so
important i want to thank producer james
childs and associate producer kelly
daniel my co-host
john deloney who is so graceful at
handling
hard situations just like that this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright and
joining me today is dr
john deloney we are celebrating the
kickoff
of the pre-order of my new book take
back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance we
are celebrating it
talking about time management today if
you want to get your copy to get all
the pre-order bonus items you can go to
ramseysolutions.com
and get your copy and we're taking your
calls as always
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
we are talking about all things life and
money we want to help you
get the advice and direction that you
need that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five and before we go to
the calls yes give us 30 seconds on this
book
i'm excited about it well it's like we
were talking about earlier john
the a lot of people feel like they want
balance but they don't know what it is
they just know they don't have it and so
i've taken this elusive idea of balance
and then given them a very specific path
to get it so i don't think life balance
is doing everything for an equal amount
of time
doing the right things at the right time
and when you do that you feel the sense
of balance you've been looking for and
it's been cool to see the feedback
already from our early readers
they're like oh wow this is so practical
and that's what i wanted for a hard
topic like balance
so if you're listening to this and you
have to drive
90 miles an hour to get to work every
day or you're eating
lunch in your lap while you're on the
phone
and you're driving with your knee and
you're reaching back to hand your kid
their sippy cup
or if you're married to somebody or
dating somebody and you feel like
if one if they just misreplace their
toothbrush this whole house of cards is
coming down
this book is for them and for
you and this is me looking in the mirror
hey let's be honest it's for me that's
why i wrote it authors write what they
need and i'm like
whether you're scattered you're over
committed you
worry that you spend much time on your
phone like we all do all the things
you don't need more time you just need
to spend the time you have on the right
things
and it'll help you do that all right
let's go to denver we've got amber
in denver colorado hey amber how are you
hi john and christy um i am calling
because i
am struggling with my what's up i've
been marriage for
i've been married for two and a half
years um it's actually my second
marriage
um and when i married my husband i had a
long list of
things that he needed to check off
before i decided to get married and he
checked off a lot of those boxes
and uh hold on just hold on hold on hold
on hold on
before you go any further i just humor
me
what are some of the things on your on
your on your magical
mythical uh fantasy list um
kind uh let's see what reliable
um keep going those are those are the
easy ones
give us the ones that are gonna make me
roll my eyes uh um
sturdy stable um
sturdy really sturdy like i'm looking at
a guy in the lobby
that's got about 150 pounds of just raw
beef on him
he's ripped i mean i i just think
somebody's um
that kind of passionate and easy easy
going
is the right way to put it passionate
and easy going okay continue
no no not not passionate not passionate
easy going okay um
compassionate
yeah um and
he he i think for him his checklist was
more like
um you know stable good with money has
comes from a good family
type thing and we're kind of coming to
this pivotal moment in our relationship
where we
are realizing that we don't have that we
never had like the love spark
and i'm really struggling trying to
figure out if
that's actually an unnecessary thing to
have
so a yes you should you should man
you're saying all the things
if this feels like a like uh i'm not
even gonna go there
you're saying all the things um so yes
you have to love the person that you're
married to that's that's a
one of the cornerstones of marriage is i
love the person
um i often wince
when somebody says we're coming to this
apex moment especially when it's two and
a half years in
um that feels like you have set yourself
up for a
determined outcome that you want and you
want to blame it on a moment
right so why'd you marry this guy
if he's sturdy and compassionate and
kind and lovely
yeah and i promise that he wanted you
for more than
you were good with money yeah right
right
my first marriage was pretty tumultuous
and there's a lot of
um there was a lot of passion and love
but it ended
badly yep um there was an infidelity and
addiction
and so i knew that i guess i
feel like i didn't trust that anymore
and i wanted something a little bit more
stable and reliable
okay and
i i i'm just like i guess i'm struggling
because i always believed i could just
cool
we could just cultivate something that
was worth it but it feels a little bit
more like
an arranged marriage type situation and
and it's been a few years since i looked
at it it's been a few years since i
looked at the data
but arrange marriages over time when
they decide they're going to put the
work in they love each other
the data on that suggests that they last
a long long time
yeah and so what i'll tell you is you've
got a lot more choice in this than
you're allowing yourself
um christy you're i can feel you just
moving
like almost uh
well no i can feel it from you well when
well when you were saying the checklist
amber
when you were saying the checklist of
what you wanted in a spouse
i already knew what your previous
relationship was because your checklist
was pretty consistent
and typically when someone is passionate
i'm looking for these things kind
compassionate stable i'm like well she's
been somewhere where she didn't get that
because otherwise she wouldn't be so
definitive i need these things like
you've been hurt you've been wounded
uh i i think there's an element of this
and john i actually want to throw back
to you on this on this aspect of
i think people view marriage differently
as a believer as a child of divorced
parents
i'm like no i'm in it i'm in it unless
i'm in it yeah but that's how i view
marriage everyone doesn't view marriage
like that
everyone doesn't view marriage depending
on your faith and so i think how you
view marriage
greatly i would imagine affects how you
make decisions
because i hear this as hard make the
choice to love each other
work at it stick with it and and turn it
into what you want it to be
but everyone doesn't see it like that
and yeah well you just feel like you
need to you just said something that is
countercultural yet scientifically
accurate which is make the choice to
love esther perel is the one um who
first put me on to this which is
it used to be historically that we put
um we got our security and our stability
from
our institutions right from our small
villages from our churches from our
local schools
and as those institutions have shifted
and changed over time
we've looked at a our marriage partner
and said you are everything
your stability you're my love you're my
romantic you're my passion so here's the
thing
you've got stability you've got kindness
you've got a person of character
desire is something that you practice it
is something you say i'm gonna be about
and he's gonna be about it too and y'all
are gonna have
the adventure of a lifetime practicing
desire
you've got the stability and the safety
now you decide we're not
this marriage is not gonna end we're
gonna practice desire and we're gonna be
all in and you're gonna look up in six
months and you're gonna be so in love
with this dude
that your house is on fire that's good
that's good do you think disney
movies have ruined us i think they have
they destroyed everything
this is the ramsay show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
dr john dolone
and you know john you have actually been
a guest on my show
the christy wright show which is my
weekly podcast and youtube show
and when you were on recently i asked
you about something that i think is so
perfect for what
we were just talking about in the last
segment and something else i want to
talk about and
this is something that you have helped
me and my husband with
you give me some advice a while back and
we were talking about expectations and
communication
and you said you've got to talk in
pictures you've got to talk in pictures
instead of saying what do you want to do
saturday oh let's have a fun day
specify what fun means to you and what
that means to matt because so often in
marriage i think we miss each other
and he says one thing i say another
thing we think we're saying the same
thing and then we end up somebody's
frustrated because we didn't do what we
said we want to do and you said speak in
pictures that was one example that you
have given me such
great advice in marriage because we do
this now so hey freddy what do you want
to do friday night what does that look
like to you
i know you have worked with a lot of
couples and you actually have an event
coming up
money and marriage with rachel cruz tell
us about your event because this is one
of those things where
if someone was listening to the last
call yeah and they're relating to that
going hey
we're in a tough place we want to do
what you just said
we want to make an effort how do we do
that sometimes it helps to have outside
people come alongside you and support
you and encourage you and give you
practical steps like you gave me
in terms of speaking in pictures so talk
a little bit about the event when it is
how people can get tickets all like this
yes when i think about that couple that
we i mean that woman that was just on
the call
if you're sitting in a counseling
context
that's a dream like nobody's cheating on
anybody
right nobody's um unethical nobody's
mean nobody's abusive
it's just we don't have this spark and
because since we
since we're thinking in in we haven't
thought in pictures we're just
thinking i should be feeling this way i
don't feel this way oh my gosh that
tells me that we're missing some
some tactical skills right just some
things we can practice
so this weekend we got money and
marriage event it's friday night
this friday listen put the kids to bed
put them in another room i'll even give
you a pass just to hand them a screen
for an hour and a half
um just hand them a screen in the room
and say hey deloney approved this for
one night you can do this
it's me and rachel listen we are six
months out of 2020.
everybody hit the gas it's like shaking
up a two-liter bottle i was hoping that
we would just open the top gently we
didn't we opened it up and now
it's stuff is everywhere um where
everybody's exhausted they're flying by
we've had vacations this
everybody's just running chaos and the
thing that gets put on the back burners
are marriages
right so it's time to reconnect bring
back the spark romance
we are gonna be talking about sex we're
gonna be talking about connection we're
gonna be talking about
all new stuff and listen we can't like
man we are halfway through this year and
i'll just leave it at that it's gonna um
it's gonna be awesome it's i think
prices are 30 bucks
text marriage to three three seven eight
nine it's to be me and rachel it's all
new content all new stuff
um it's going to be a lot of fun it's
going to be a lot of laughter and you're
going to walk away with some real
um tips on how to just like that last
couple i said hey you need to practice
desire
i know millions of people just listen to
that and go what is that what are you
talking about practice desire
i just look at him and he's just sitting
on the couch with cheetos on his shirt
all right practice desire with that guy
i'm gonna give you
some tips and tricks okay so um
text marriage to three three seven eight
nine it's 30
bucks for crying out loud you can't even
leave your house for that much
um set it up watch it it's gonna be fun
marriage
marriage text marriage two three three
seven eight nine for some of you that
may struggle with spelling that word
like i do i get the i'm the a makes up
listen m-a-r-r-i-a-g-e
i'm just you gonna have the misspellings
being texted that number they're not
gonna get them three three seven eight
nine it's this friday night
um man we'd love to see you there and
it's gonna be a blast me and rachel cruz
and i just want to call out some people
are listening listen especially for the
women
or men if you've been complaining to
your friends about your spouse
listen it's time to actually invest in
your marriage stop complaining about
things stop making excuses
actually do something about it invest in
this part of your life
if you want it to be better so often we
complain about things and then we just
don't do anything to make it better this
is a great practical way
to invest in it in a way that will make
it better
where you actually get different results
so you guys get your tickets i'm so
excited about this
uh yeah no tell me if you have been
married
i don't know more than a couple years i
don't know anybody you may be the first
i don't know anybody who hasn't
sat down with a friend or two and said
hey i don't know if this is the right
thing
right i don't know if i made
man we're too far apart to come back we
should not have done this i think i'm
ready to cash out
i don't know anybody who hasn't had
those thoughts those experiences
um this is a low-key lo-fi
fun way yet very serious way um
as you just said just sit down on the
couch together
sit in the opposite reclining chairs
together
and do something together you don't have
to leave your house you don't have to
get all dramatic and make a counseling
appointment
um do this together don't quit don't
quit don't quit on your marriage
yeah i would just one thing i would
speak to with people that are maybe in
my season cause i'll tell you what i
struggle with more than that
is being in a season of young children
six four and a half and one and a half
they will suck the life out of your
marriage marriage becomes business do
you have the kids do you have the dry
cleaning who's getting dinner who's
cleaning the house you it's like we are
just managing our household
yeah we miss you because co-workers yeah
and and it takes us getting out of that
getting child care getting out of that
to go oh there you are
there we are we there we are you know
and and so for anybody even if you're
not in extreme like crisis mode in your
marriage where you're doubting your
your marriage or wondering what you know
a really hard season it might just be
the grind marriage has become business
of running errands and keeping up with
kids and changing diapers and this is a
great way
to remember who you were before kids who
you are in addition to kids
to get back to that and like you said
practice practice build something new
practice loving each other yeah can i
ask you this question yeah
a few words in the world get my heart
rate up
and my adrenaline and cortisol spiked
more than the word
snacks christy wright if my kids say the
words
i want to snack well i can't handle it
am i crazy
let me tell you why they're eating
dinner they will say
what's for snack while they're have food
in their hands
sure yeah no i'm with you america i hate
the word snack
and i would like to propose on behalf of
the ramsay show
that we just get rid of that word
completely did we never say the word
snack again
i'm sick of i can't handle the word man
we have a snack
oh my gosh one of my morning routines
that i have instituted a while ago and
actually talk about this in the book but
i wake up before my kids even though i
have little ones
i say even though they wake up early i
set my alarm for about 30 minutes before
them even if it's only 15
i have to wake up his mom because if not
i wake up too
i want a snack where's my milk where's
my clothes he looked at me wrong
he put on mickey mouse i just get
screamed at from the moment i open my
eyes to consciousness
and i just need to wake up to me i just
need to wake up to not being mom
and that small moment in time
gives me 15 minutes before i get yelled
out about snacks because it snacks the
rest of the day and every other need
that they have
[Laughter]
other needs are fine change my diaper
sure you got that hey can we go fishing
abs
not today but hey we need to mow the
yacht crate can i have a snack can i
have a snack i have a snack
hey look that place has snacks it's just
a word i think snack is
latin for i i hate you i think that's
what that means
all right so money and marriage this
friday night
invest in your marriage you will be glad
that you did all right we've got lee
calling in from portland hey lee how's
it going
uh it's going pretty well thank you how
can i help
uh my question is is it ethically and
morally right to accept paid to care for
my special needs adult daughter
so um i guess walk me through the other
give me some more details
there yeah okay yeah so uh
i have friends family acquaintances
that have been advising me this is the
way to go
uh i can get paid to care for her
but i've been struggling with this for
quite a while because i know that it's
quite possibly
um you know tax money that's probably
paying for it
and i i just i
i don't know if i feel right taking it
being paid to do something to be mom
yeah okay lee this is a really
interesting question and i want to make
sure that we
give you a good answer and do it justice
so we gotta we gotta hop to break here
in a second but stay on the line
and we will pick it back up when we come
back from break and um dr john dalone
and i will dig into this for you stay on
the line for us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
dr john dolone and just before the break
we were talking to lee in portland and
we kind of ran out of time so we want to
go ahead
and pick up that conversation lee um
john deloney and i have uh just some
follow-up questions for you
can you tell us a little bit more about
the um details around the arrangement i
know you were asking about is it morally
and ethically okay for you to accept
payments to care for your special needs
adult daughter but what are the
what are kind of the regulations around
that how much money would it be can you
work give us some more
specifics there so i what i
understand is i can apply to be
my own daughter's caregiver um which
there are people who have um caregivers
that
are i don't i'm not
i don't fully know the details um
exactly but you can get paid up like 15
an hour or something to be your child's
caregiver as opposed to someone coming
from the outside
to do the same thing and so why do you
feel guilty about that
it i don't know because it's my job to
be mom
right how old is she 25.
okay do you work do you have another job
yes i do
what do you do in your other job um i
work
in member services
okay gotcha so um christy
feel free to weigh in on this i i see
absolutely no problem with this and
here's why
number one you're gonna hire care anyway
for your adult daughter there is no
better care
on planet earth than you mom someone who
loves their daughters known for 25 years
number two this is going to require you
to cut back some hours for your day job
if not all of them
you're going to have to make a number of
financial concessions
and i actually love i'm a taxpayer pay a
lot of taxes
i don't have a problem with this type of
arrangement because
um you're gonna have to make that
financial you're gonna have to make that
money up somewhere else
and so at some point you're gonna have
your daughter's gonna need care
i have no problem with it being you i do
understand what you're where you're
coming from
but there is a time for being mom and
there is a time
for um
that medical care that special needs
care that driving back and forth to
appointments
um don't get those tangled up mom's
about love and showing up and it is
about caring and doing whatever i'll go
to the ends of earth and all that stuff
and it's all right and true
but i've got absolutely no moral or
ethical problem with you doing this
christie
lee the other thing i just want to
commend you first of all your daughter's
25 so she is an adult like you you have
been mom
of a child and you raised your child to
be 25
and because of the unique situation with
her having special needs
um i'd be willing to bet that no one
other than maybe our listeners right now
that have been in similar shoes of
having a special needs child
no one understands what you have been
through
no one understands the sacrifices you've
made no one understands the money you've
spent
no one understands how hard that road
has been for you
and even will continue to be as you care
for her and so for you to have some
additional money
to help you offset the cost of what
you're doing to care for her
and additionally the the sacrifices from
whatever you have to cut back on your
own income
that is absolutely appropriate
it is absolutely appropriate for you to
have that additional care for you to
have that additional income
and i would be willing to bet that every
single parent of a special needs child
would agree with
would agree with me on that um that's a
hard road
and uh and you need all the support you
can get so i am i
i hope that answers your question i hope
it also just gives you permission
to get what you need to do what you want
to do
um which it sounds like is is care for
your child so thanks for calling i love
it what a heart lee good for you we have
such a um
gosh it's when it's money there's so
many emotions tangled up in it isn't it
like it's like we've got all these
feelings about it whether it's something
like that or even
i mean this is a completely opposite
example but i i see similarities with um
uh women i help with business they feel
guilty for charging right and they're
providing a product or service
they're like well i feel bad yeah i'm
like why do you feel bad i don't know i
just feel bad taking money from people
should just be it's that magic word i
should right oh my gosh we have so
i must i should many emotions with money
uh speaking of emotions with money a lot
of times i think
our emotions can drive our decisions and
our behavior with money we get
in a situation we don't want to be in we
need help getting it together if you are
struggling
with money if you're struggling with
keeping up with payments
you know what it's like to be so scared
and so overwhelmed
you can't think straight emotions have
taken over
but here's the good news you don't have
to live like that anymore
when you pay off your debt as fast as
possible like we
teach and like millions of americans
have done with our plan you will never
have that kind of stress in your life
again you can do this
and here's where you start financial
peace university
millions of people have taken this class
and learned how to pay off debt
and take control of their money you can
stream all nine lessons right now
or get some extra support by going
through the class with other people
and the only way to get financial peace
university is with a ramsey
plus membership you can get rid of that
debt that's holding you back
and in the cycle of worry and
stress to start your free trial of
ramsay plus just text
trial to 33789
that's trial two three three seven
eight nine you know john i went through
financial peace university in 2012
and i was already on my debt-free
journey but it just kick-started it even
faster because i actually had a plan and
whether it's like we were talking about
earlier earlier whether it's managing
your time
managing your money running a marathon
when you have a plan on paper you know
that you can do it because you can see
it
you can see what the steps are yeah and
hey if you if you text
um trial to three three seven eight nine
and you are part of the free trial you
can stream the money and marriage event
for free oh how about your and ramsay
plus these kind of cool things show up
and you get
free access to the to the live stream
events and this is one of them coming up
friday so if you take advantage of this
free trial today
you can also stream that event this
weekend for free all right that's trial
to 33789
trial to 33789 you get your ramsey plus
membership kickstart your money
plan and you get access to a money and
marriage event with john delony
rachel cruz this friday night we've had
kind of a theme today
with marriage calls and so i think it's
perfect timing with that to show people
things that you can do habits that you
can create
to change your outcome john what is uh
one thing that you are most excited
about teaching people talking about
speaking on this friday night
what aspect of it that's a great
question
probably i for some reason
we can make humans together
we can share bathrooms
we can share meals but when it comes to
talking about sex and intimacy when it
comes to talking about
money and when it comes to talking about
dreams
like what do we want what do we want
what's the picture of our life
gonna look like um we our mouths go dry
we don't know what to say yeah we don't
want to talk about it we're so
nervous about rejection and man when you
talk about intimacy you talk about money
there's so much baggage there there's so
much hurt there there's so much
um cultural narrative and family history
and
old um stories we tell ourselves so much
goes into that
and so at some point somebody just has
to turn all the lights on turn the music
off and say hey can we just be honest
with each other for a minute yeah and
it's the same way dave does it with
money
just says hey i know what the culture's
telling you know what the world's
telling you
just listen if you do it like this and
so
it's the same it's just teaching people
how to talk to talk to one another you
know this is a silly example but when i
was in high school
i joined the track team and i you know
you you expect that
running is one of those things you're
born knowing how to do right like you
crawl them walk then run and
kids run all over the playground and so
you think running like what would you
learn
and running and i remember the track
team in high school i learned
form and drills and i got faster and
faster and the faster i got
the more i wanted to run because i
learned all the proper technique of
something that i thought i was supposed
to know how to do
and i think that we feel that way about
marriage yeah and friendship
even like sex and intimacy you think
you're supposed to know yeah you know me
like what to talk about how to do
and so because because we expect that
we're supposed to know how to do all
these things or raise kids
communicate with our spouse whatever
because we expect that we're supposed to
know how to do it we're supposed to be
born knowing how to do it
we're afraid to ask we're afraid to get
outside help we're afraid to talk to our
spouse about it
and that's why i'm so excited you guys
are doing this event where you are going
to talk about those things and give
people the language around it to talk
about it but also the specific steps
they can take on these things that guess
what
you're not born knowing how to do if we
will just
take a deep breath and step back and
look at relationships
marriages friendships even with a
loneliness epidemic
and look at them as a series of skills
that we don't have
and now i can go grab some skills the
same as i do when i want to learn a song
on guitar
when i want to fix something under my
sink i just need some skills
man you can take all the drama out of it
and we go get some of this done and heal
relationships all
over the country so good this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guarantee
means that even if you mismeasure or
pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promotions they run
every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal
all right today's question comes from
laurie in california
i'm a single mother with a 17 year old
son i'm working the baby steps to
financially prepare for the end
of child support in my future retirement
i'm in baby step two with fifty thousand
dollars in debt and make about sixty
five thousand dollars a year
i attended business boutique and have a
side etsy business which i had to put on
hold
to tutor my son through some school
challenges this year now that he's on a
more solid education footing
should i focus on building the business
again to get more income
for the baby steps there's a lot going
on here
yeah there it is um you know what's
interesting is a lot of times when
people ask about business should i
focus on building the business again
it's
there's usually some more information
that's missing because if you can build
the business and not spend any money on
it
yes if you can build the business and
you have the time or can make the time
yes but if you're in a season where
it's going to cost a lot of money to get
it off the ground or you just
do not have the time it would be your
time would be better spent in a
full-time job or something then no so i
think
it's one of those things where one of
the things i love to help people do john
is i love to help people
in their business regardless of their
type of business get
profitable fast so sometimes people will
come to me with this big idea like i
wanna
i wanna buy land and build an event
space and i wanna have big events i'm
like that's awesome
can you just sublease a warehouse down
the road and put some events there and
prove your concept first
you know what i mean because i think
sometimes we have the cadillac version
of our idea
or we have um we just want
we want to put a bunch of money into it
and i want to figure out i want to help
you figure out how to
build the thing and not put a bunch of
money into it i want to help you make a
bunch of money growing slow i mean this
this business is an example we started
on a card table in dave ramsey's living
room
right you know growing at the speed of
cash so i got a letter today
which i love a handwritten letter or it
was typed
and so walk me through what this would
look like so somebody wrote in and said
my husband and i want to we we're
looking at the st the data the stats
on minister burnout and you can put
dr burnout dentist burnout teacher
burnout um
we just fry helping professionals right
but this particular
family was interested in starting a
retreat center
getting a bunch of land starting a place
for ministers to come
heal their marriages heal their lives
and get stuff back together
um walk me through what you would tell
that person
like it sounds like they're starting to
their sounds like they're starting with
the end in mind which is this magical
ranch
like 30 tiny houses that you can be full
of all the time
that's not reality reality is we're here
we have no land
yeah we all work construction job what
would that look like right well i think
that there's two implications there's
the
financial implication of you have to
have the cash to go buy that land and
build that place but there's also the
risk implication that you haven't proven
this idea yet
you think it'll be a huge success do
people want to come spend time with you
right and i hope that it is
but we need to prove the concept so i'll
give you an example
of a friend of mine actually this was
years ago he had an idea to start a
cookie delivery business he worked a
full-time job
and instead of going and leasing a
retail store front in the middle of
downtown nashville committing to a
10-year lease and spending all this
money for a build out and all this stuff
for an idea that he had not proven
what he did was he found a commercial
kitchen downtown
that only operated from eight to five he
went in proposed his idea and said hey
i want to start a cookie delivery
business in the evenings can i come in
your off hours
after 5 pm and bake and use your kitchen
and they said yes and so he had no risk
no commitment the financial investment
was almost nothing it was just his
ingredients right for the cookies and he
cash flowed it he continued to cash flow
at cash flow cash flow it built this
awesome cookie delivery business in
downtown nashville delivered to
vanderbilt students
parents would send cookies to their kids
studying for exams
built it up built up over years of
working in the evenings after
his full-time job so he had the
stability of his income but what he was
doing was proving the concept
he was getting cash in improving the
concept and then
i think it was after a couple years got
a storefront
and then eventually after the store
front was so successful sold it
and so he's just had this awesome
evolution of his business
but it's not because he had an idea and
turned that into a big risk
you grow at the speed of cash and so in
that case i would find what does an
event venue look like what is a
is there some non-traditional space that
you could use
to do the that's in their off hours in
their off weekends dates times whatever
to host events there provide the healing
provide the concept on a 1.0 version i
use the
iphone as an example the iphone's on the
iphone what now 12.
they started with the iphone one they
didn't do half of the things that it
does now right it didn't have the camera
that it has now it didn't have the
functionality that it has now
but they put something out there in the
in the world the 1.0 version and they
listen to the market and they iterate
and improve and iterate and prove and
prove concept
and get money in and then put 2.0 3.0 et
cetera so i just i recommend people come
up with their
1.0 version of that idea what is a
creative
low-cost low-risk version of that idea
where you can prove concept and get cash
and then cash flow it over time so that
you have low risk
in in all of the ownership and so i
think that's just a
safer way to do it how do you teach
somebody christy
to let me say it this way i love
feedback i like to okay you gave a talk
to and it wasn't great
here's how we can make it better it was
you didn't you didn't hit the mark on
this or
this was kind of funny we could have
done this better your show needs to do
this i like that
um because i don't want to spend my time
and my life's too short right
um but i also know sometimes those
things are sensitive right so let's take
your cookie friend
the proof of concept hey can you make
cookies can you work hard yes i can do
all these things i've got this great
business plan
actually looks good on paper to me the
cornerstone question there is
do people like your cookies are they
good yeah right or
are you a kind of person that
people whose marriages are struggling
want to come spend time with you or
do you bring people peace how do you
teach people
to go out on that limb and
solicit feedback accept feedback be able
to say well
i want to start a cookie shop i'm not
great at baking yeah i think i think you
have to reframe
failure because if you're all sensitive
about your cookies or your marriage
counseling and you think that someone
giving you feedback that isn't perfect
is a failure or criticism then you're
never going to look for it you're never
going to seek it you're not going to
listen to it
but you view business like a scientist
scientists never fail
they're just experimenting they're just
trying to be less wrong everything is an
experiment yeah if an experiment goes
wrong it's like well i'll learn from
that and another one went wrong i
learned from that
everything is an experiment so see that
as an experiment in my cookie friend
example
he sent all of his friends cookies and
said are they good he sent me some he
said matt and i sent to our house when
we lived in sloven park
friends are the worst they never do that
my friends wanna
but he literally asked this question
were they warm were they soft did i mean
did they taste good which flavor was
your favorite
he sought out that but he saw it as
research
he saw it as an experiment and so
whatever idea you have
if it is a business idea if it is a
ministry idea non-profit for-profit it
doesn't matter
seek out that feedback and then you make
changes based on the feedback we do that
internally
we put out surveys we this this cover of
my book
is the cover that the the survey people
picked yeah we had six covers this is
the one they picked
and so ask people feedback to know what
they like and what they want and your
idea is going to be better
but then in business i love what dave
ramsey says business is a conversation
with the marketplace
you never just come out with the iphone
and you never fix your iphone you never
come out with a cookie recipe and you
never update it probably
you're probably always making it better
figuring out how to deliver them where
they're going to stay warmer
you're always iterating on whatever your
idea is to make it better
for your customers it's a conversation
with
the marketplace all right i want to
share with you guys our scripture and
quote of the day
our scripture is matthew 6 26.
look at the birds of the air they do not
sow or reap
or store away in barns and yet your
heavenly father feeds them
are you not much more valuable than they
our quote today
the invariable mark of wisdom is to see
the miraculous
in the common ralph waldo
baby i love it man what a perfect quote
for what we've been talking about in
marriage
it's a little stuff man see the
miraculous in the comments see
that your spouse is showing you love by
taking out the trash
see the miraculous in the common even in
the day-to-day grind that's so good john
this was fun thank you
thanks for hanging out with me and
congratulations on the launch of your
books
go to thermsy.com and get your copy
so good can't wait thank you thank you
also i want to thank producer james
child
associate producer kelly daniel and you
america for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you